et claire évidemment c'est d'essayer de
se qualifier pour les quarts de finale
c'est possible on sait que la
compétition est relevée avec désormais
seize équipes dans quatre groupes de
quatre les les choses sont claires il
faut sortir parmi les deux premiers de
ce groupe pour passer en quarts de
finale donc c'est l'objectif qu'on se
fixe et les moyens vont essayer d'être
mis au service de cet objectif avec les
une préparation on est on est en train
de travailler tout de suite sur un stage
de préparation qu'on on fera très
certainement évidemment aux états unis
et puis bien sûr la la composition de la
meilleure délégation possible pour
mettre les chances les meilleures
chances possibles du côté de la
martinique